have you guys ever had like a spa day or
like going to like spas winning room by
yourself
i haven't gone by myself i went by
myself have you been by yourself you
haven't been by yourself i mean like i
mean sometimes you go to a hotel and
like sydney just goes for like a spa day
and i'm just like i'm it's you know what
i don't really like spa days because
that's like that's like three hours of
my life that i could be doing relaxing
doing something self-care go on
self-care is it self-care though yeah is
it self-care
how much how much more of a benefit does
it do like health-wise
you reckon i don't know just i mean it's
if it you know or is it purely just like
mental stress stress is a big killer
right so if you can that's what i mean
is it purely a mental thing well yeah
because it's a mental distress but like
having your body like beaten up or
massaged that's not that's not that's
not relaxing so for some people it's
very relaxing to have that you know i
tried it once actually when we were
staying at a hotel with aki you know
he's like come on just try it just try
it once and i'm like all right fine i'll
try it once i wasn't it was like a three
hour course and i was like yeah [ __ ]
sake that's three hours of my life gone
okay
and i was like all right you know what
i won't do that again but that was that
was relaxing so low is my blood pressure
until i see the price how much
400 bucks the [ __ ]
the stress comes right i don't like
doing spa days well alex came with the
deal
oh yeah so i was like oh it's free [ __ ]
yeah i'll do it all right yeah yeah and
i was like it's good but like if i had
to pay 400 bucks for it enough yeah i
could never dedicate more than an hour
to something to doing something that's
meant to be i guess relaxing and i
didn't even experience like two-thirds
of it because i was asleep
i do like i literally woke up i
literally fell asleep while they were
giving me a massage and then two hours
later they were like all right you're
done
i was like oh good
that was a great experience i did fall
asleep in a massage once actually
i just don't remember anything that
happened clearly you were sleeping yeah
you were a sleeper i just felt like i
wasted money because i fell asleep back
up yeah but like like i mean that's kind
of the point right either you fall
asleep or you
get beating the [ __ ] out and if you're
apparently better afterwards apparently
i feel like
when i fell asleep i was like i don't
remember anything was it worth it i
don't know i don't really feel more
relaxed i just slept in the middle of
the day right you could have done that
in your hotel bed right honestly
honestly that's what i prefer to do i
prefer just browsing my phone because
the thing the thing about the spa days
is that you're kind of forced to do
nothing yeah wait wait wait wait wait
wait what do what do you want to do on
vacation what do you want to do what's
your what's your ideal vacation i think
we've said this before right but i i
just don't want to do anything i just
want to sit in my room i like that a lot
of the time i like you i want days where
i explore but i also want days where i
just sit in the room and do nothing oh
yeah yeah i appreciate the rooms
facilities yeah and just relax my
optimal thing is to just walk around
town and just find good things to eat
yeah that's honestly the best vacation
if i don't have a good meal to look
forward to vacation room or vacation
like four meals five meals a day oh yeah
i just turned into just an absolute
glutton yeah like ice cream after every
meal don't mind if i do but then my my
idea for it is like yes i'm eating a lot
but i'll walk it off i'm walking
i'm like yes i'm eating a lot and i like
it yeah like like
it's vacation i will like i remember um
in the camping trip that we went on uh i
remember like the first night so the fir
the first time we went to uh went
camping it was [ __ ] typhooning yeah
right so
like we got there and like we we we
really tried to camp right we were just
like we will
we'll [ __ ] a little bit of rain never
hurt anyone we'll try we get there it's
[ __ ] typhooning it's like it's like a
full-on monsoon the campsite's flooded
the tree is like 90. this tree is 90
degrees and nabi wearing his jeru cam
shirt just goes guys i don't think we
can do it
i've never seen i wish it was a special
so that we could film in the comments be
like nah mate just get your [ __ ] axe
out and start putting the tent down
you could have done it mate you're just
little [ __ ] yeah so we find we find
this ryokan uh to go to and you know it
was a it was a decent enough you can you
know yeah i mean how can you complain
and everything um until the point that
we needed to figure out what we were
going to eat and i'm just like cool i'm
on holiday we're gonna we're gonna find
uh we're gonna we're gonna find a
restaurant right guys but unfortunately
we didn't have lunch right so it was
like it was like this
it was like this awkward time period of
if like how you can tell you're raised
in in cities only you just didn't have
to worry about where you were eating
yeah yeah because we got there it was
like like an awkward time because none
of us had lunch and it was like like
about three about three o'clock right so
it's too late for lunch but too early
for dinner so we were just like let's
get a little snack that's at the combini
right and so we we walk we walk 15
minutes to like the nearest comedy it's
like maybe it was 10 minutes right and
we were just like oh let's let's buy
let's buy some drinks and let's buy some
snacks
and um and i remember thinking cool this
is just gonna be a quick lunch it's uh
you know we're just gonna get some
snacks and then we'll go to the
restaurant later yeah right and and then
i remember i remember on our way back
right we were just i always just
remember uh the guys had gotten like a
full-on meal and stuff like that and i
was like uh we're going out to the
restaurant again right we're going to
find a restaurant for dinner right and
it was just that [ __ ] padme meme
asking anakin
when we get back to the hotel when
everyone starts eating and everyone's
like full and i'm just like we're going
out again for dinner right guys
and then it really it finally hit god
when you heard just the crack of the
beer can i open it's like all right
we're not we're not going like i was
ready to like it was a great time with
the boys and everything but i was ready
to rate that trip zero out of ten
because i'm just like you guys i feel
like this is vastly someone did not
prepare well this should have been a
conversation that happened they were
like are we having dinner or not yeah
are we doing it now are we getting
kombini this feels like a someone [ __ ]
up oh no no someone definitely you're
all [ __ ] up yeah but you know but then
the moment we it was like you know 1pm
i'm like all right now i have to think
about dinner what are we doing for this
year i had a great [ __ ] camping trip
but i won't forget day one of my holiday
i had combini for dinner conbini food
for dinner on my holiday we fell asleep
at like 8 p.m
correction correction joey fell asleep
at 8pm because i got a [ __ ] face
i had like seven beers in like the span
of an hour and i'm like i'm on holiday
whatever you're looking for jerry cracks
open the beer and i'm ready for dinner
and joey's [ __ ] i see joey's feet and
i'm just like what what the [ __ ] is
going like
joe we're going for dinner ryan jerry's
just [ __ ] having a snooze right there
yeah
aki called me at 11 pm because because
you and luke yeah because yeah because
aki legitimately thought i'd died
because i just fell asleep at eight and
it's like why is he not responding to my
brother i'm on vacation don't text me
that was a great first day
i don't know about you it was a great
first day had a good talk with the boys
but my god that there's there's that
hole in my life i will never forget but
the problem is as well that like all of
the restaurants were also closed because
it was i think it was a public holiday
when we went so like all the rest so at
like 4 p.m all the restaurants are
closed we're like well [ __ ] yeah and
well you can't just turn to a restaurant
there was never any restaurants yeah you
had to you know now we know we'll be
very lucky now we know for next time if
you had to get a tesco meal deal maybe
one day in advance or you know make your
own food so
i just got to book a book a family mart
camping in like england you should
assume that you make your own food like
you yeah this is a given no we were
gonna do that yeah until it started
[ __ ] typhoony
in the comment you gotta do what you can
just start a fire in the car no one's
gonna notice
it yeah
that's their problem you've got
insurance don't worry about it
i want to smoke some meats in my car i'm
smoking some meats especially if it's a
rental car it's not my car i'm checking
it out
all right
ps don't smoke meat and carve that as a
joke you shouldn't smoke in the car